welcome to metaphysical milkshake i'm
your host jessica jackley and i'm your
other host holiday reinhorn and today
we're talking about motherhood obviously
a topic that we know a thing or two
about yes that's correct i almost have
an 18 year old like i'm about 30 days
away from that that's unbelievable i'm
only 10 years in uh but i have four
little ones so the math works out uh we
both have a lot to say on this topic as
women and as mothers
what's going on obviously we mean what's
going on we're it's a podcast about
motherhood
excuse me excuse me no no no no no no no
oh i'm sorry no
no we got this
we have a few things to say about
motherhood excuse me
please let the man just handle this okay
oh my god
oh geez i'm being kicked out here's the
worst brotherhood podcast maybe listen
and learn yeah okay maybe listen i think
there's some things that you could learn
from us okay uh
we'll be doing about an hour maybe a
sandwich
would that be a la
out hey don't let the don't the door hit
you on the way out of the
podcast room welcome to metaphysical
milkshake the show where we go deep we
get weird and we search for the meaning
of life along the way presented by cast
media and soul pancake
[Music]
hey hey
can you can you believe this
i mean these things
who do they think they are
jeez
we're talking about motherhood
rayne and i
as fathers have a lot to say on this a
lot to say
oh oh men can't talk about it let me
tell you ladies a little bit about
motherhood i find it very sexist
to think that a man
cannot
explain to a woman
what motherhood means i find that to be
incredibly offensive it's so limiting
it's so limiting it's a gender crime
really by the way in my household
i mean not for nothing but you know i do
all the cooking and the cleaning and the
laundry and
the shopping and
and all that stuff and jessica just sits
on the couch and scratches her quattro
area is crotch all a word
yes
stop throwing things at me
people can see this
in my household we hire people to do all
of that work so neither of us
do any of the traditional mother work
but in all seriousness certainly we are
not qualified to talk about motherhood
so we thought we would bring on someone
who is qualified to speak about
motherhood the author comedian
stand-up comic
host tv writer
award-winning she's a lot of mine is
going to be coming
a lot of things she has regularly
appeared on the showbiz show with david
spade vh1's best week ever i mean the
the the bio here is incredible cnn
commentary on the debates she was a
writer on saturday night live she was a
consulting producer on transparent and
show runner and executive producer of
the new showtime comedy series i love
that for you
about a group of people working at a
home shopping network i love that this
is her second book
her first book was a bestseller called
you'll grow out of it
and um
she's been a consulting producer on the
animated sitcom big mouth since 2017 and
she voices the main character of jesse
let's bring this
mother
expert
this motherf
expert
jesse klein to the show
jesse
hi welcome to the show
thank you so much for having me i'm so
excited to be here
oh we are excited thrilled to have you
we uh
have greatly been enjoying
savoring so good so funny your delicious
collection of essays oh my god midlife
and motherhood thank you and who better
to be talking to you about motherhood
two
middle-aged men
that's you know what i let me
get rid of any sheepishness you may be
feeling and say um
it makes me so happy to talk to men
about the book and um assuming you're
not lying about enjoying it or having
read it listen here's how we think about
it
if we can pass laws to control your body
then certainly we can have a
conversation about it yeah i mean let's
just cover all our bases
you know here on metaphysical milkshake
we try and dig deep we try and get a
little bit weird we want to explore the
topic of motherhood in perhaps a
different way maybe a profound way and
we would love to res and i were talking
before the interview like we would
actually like to
learn a little bit
about
motherhood what we want to do we want to
drink in what haven't we thought about i
have one child reza has four
young children right now
but we really want to put ourselves in
the in the shoes in the in the in the
stomach of motherhood and listen we
we're totally willing to admit that
there might be some things about
motherhood that we don't know about i
think we're i mean i'm open to that idea
i mean we have four kids i feel like
suddenly the tables have really turned
could probably be schooling me i mean
i've just got the one and it's
definitely going to be staying that way
so listen there's a lot of questions
going on right now all over the youtubes
and and media about like what is a woman
who can be a mother this is a big you
know cultural and political debate and
we're not going to go there this is no
thank you this is not that conversation
okay it we're we're stepping out of that
i mean if you have things to say we'd
love to hear but we're just
we're staying in a lane
we're staying in a lane but and and we
were talking about this first question
um earlier on like
forgive us if this is a sexist question
maybe this is a sexist question
maybe it's sexist to think that this is
a sexist question i'll be the judge yes
okay okay becoming a mother how do you
understand and view motherhood as a
fundamental part of a woman's identity
oh what is it
you were like let's go deep deep deep
we're not even going to ramp in we're
going to go 60 billion you thought we
were going to be like what made you want
to write a book
where'd you go to college yeah
we're going right straight to the center
of the vagina on this question
i i feel like there's a lot of
overlap in my observations around sort
of
how
certain kind of
femininity and womanhood that our
society and culture
prizes and praises and um
demands
really overlaps with kind of the view of
motherhood in our culture which is like
you're supposed to kind of just shut up
and do it
and be as kind of quiet as possible
about it and make it as pretty as
possible so that no one else is
uncomfortable and i think for
mothers and women who aren't mothers i
think like trying to operate within
those um prescribed little
boxes is emotionally untenable
that's a lot of where the book came from
and just i think a lot of my experience
especially in the really early years my
son is seven now um
but it just felt like oh my god i'm
having such an unruly emotional response
to all of this it feels so hard and so
messy and i'm not seeing sort of the
room for that reflected back and like
any
any popular culture around motherhood
in the same way that when i was like a
teenage girl i didn't feel like i really
was seeing reflections of like what i
was actually going through
in in anything you know i feel like i
grew up in a visual culture that's
you know it's like just be very thin and
be very pretty and ideally white and
just and that really gets into your head
and i think like i just always go back
to an image i realize i'm really
rambling but this feels like a safe
space totally
plus we have an edit button so it's fine
you're not we're gonna we're gonna cut
out all that
i think i've always liked diaper ads
like bait those little diapers like
diaper ads where you see a mother just
like
holding her infant and it's like the
most vaseline lens and everyone's
smiling and she looks great and the baby
looks great and
and it's like everyone's just in some
kind of little
gauzy heaven no one's covered in [ __ ] no
it's covered in [ __ ] but i mean the
covered in [ __ ] thing i kind of talk
about in the book too a little bit i
think if i remember
uh i guess i'm talking about it now if i
didn't but like the covered in [ __ ]
thing i will say is the one like trope
that you sometimes see in like comedies
that are quote unquote made for moms
she's covered in poop and like that's
the punch line
of the thing
but it it's like that's i mean you're
both parents so i'm assuming you know
like that's kind of
that's not pleasant but it also doesn't
really matter like the feel
the real mess is so much darker than
that
you know the mess of like what's going
on inside of you what's happening to
your identity the anger and frustration
and rage you might be feeling like i
don't really care about the poop on the
clothes i mean you know you do but
anyways that's a very long answer but
you sure set yourself up for it with a
deep deep
question you literally said like being a
woman is difficult dark and messy and
growing up one and being a mother is
even more difficult dark and messy and
culturally you're not really supported
for that part of the story but i'm
interested i'm interested in that uh
that
i think the
kind of the dark side of of of womanhood
and motherhood which has been for
decades so
you know so suppressed you know i we
don't want to hear about that you know
they would literally hysterectomies was
like you're hysterical and we're going
to cut the uterus out of you you know
and pull a francis farmer on you yeah i
can't even imagine how challenging that
must be yeah i mean i think you know a
lot of the feedback that i've gotten
from the book which has been very
very satisfying to have heard
from so many women who've written to me
and i don't mean to be tooting my own
horn about this i'm really saying this
in a way because it's been quite
touching
because a lot of women have reached out
to say thank you for writing this like i
i finally feel seen
like especially mothers who have very
young children just to
hear that like that what you're going
through counts as a story and that
there's gravitas to it and that it is a
hero's journey for people to go through
this and it matters as much as any
sort of more cliche
quote-unquote bigger story
in the
world of tales that we're used to seeing
you know i think like heroes journey
like we think about star wars and lord
of the rings and
things like that where like a man goes
to a far away place and conquer
something or fight somebody but
i think like these stories of
of women and um the journey they're on
as they protect and raise their children
is
is of equal heft and import were you one
of these people and i say people not
women because i was definitely one of
these people who
always thought about having kids
like wanted to have kids like was it
like a drive of yours or
you know i i'm just curious kind of the
way that you thought about motherhood in
theory
as opposed to
you know the reality of it
no totally so you always wanted to give
you knew you wanted to be bad always in
fact i uh i uh rain rain knows this
about me i've been engaged four times
because i wouldn't i would like meet a
girl and be like you look like you have
child bearing hips let's get married
uh fortunately it never it never worked
out until it finally did like until the
one that's done yeah the one that's
stuck exactly
that's so interesting i never think
about i feel like i
wait and rain did you feel that way or
no did you always know you wanted to be
a dad i never hear men talk about this
oh yeah i always wanted to be a dad yeah
that was that was definitely one of the
roles i wanted to play and it was it was
tricky for me and my wife because
all of a sudden we found ourselves in
our mid late 30s and we're like uh oh
biological clock
and then we had trouble conceiving and
it took us like a year and a half two
years something like that and my wife i
think similar to you my wife was 40 when
she had our son yeah and it was a very
difficult and traumatic birth so we're
we
that's so interesting thank you for
sharing that yeah i never i i
never felt compelled towards motherhood
i had a couple of friends who like
always people i
i'm very lucky to have some friends from
when i was pretty young
like elementary school junior high
school friends and
a couple of them i know really always
always knew they wanted to be mothers
and i i definitely did not
i just i i felt like i was uh
i don't know i don't know why i didn't i
i didn't have strong feelings kind of
against it i just
i was just driven by other things
i didn't really get there
until kind of the moment was really like
after i got married and i was also quite
you know geriatric in these terms they
do use that term like geriatric
pregnancy i'm sure you're familiar with
i think if you're like 36 or about right
you're like
pregnant
high risk or something i was kind of
trying to find out how late i could push
push the buzzer beater because my
my spouse was interested in having a
child and then in the process of like
doing a routine
fertility check where i was like well
let's just find out i can wait till
forever
it was revealed i had like less than
zero eggs left or whatever and then it
became like this huge panic and negative
number of eggs
no negative eggs that's my first album
nobody buys it when i found out i had
negative eggs i i
i flipped out and i was like
for whatever reason i guess it maybe
sounds kind of small
and a little like tracy flickish or
something like oh i'm gonna do the thing
i've just been told i can't do but i
really
when faced at that age i guess with
never having a kid i suddenly wanted to
have a kid very badly
ran you seem like a brunch kind of guy
right you're a lovely person i love i
love it i love it most important meal of
the day
most important meal of the day is brunch
and my assumption is that you know
before you go out to eddie brunch place
you pour over lists and lists of reviews
right you want to make sure you go into
a quality place yes you got it well then
why don't you do the same when you're
booking a doctor disappointment hey he's
off
sorry i was a little that was a little
too impassioned but that's how i feel
about zocdoc my friend see with zocdoc
you can see real verified patient
reviews to help find the right doctor in
your network and in your neighborhood
after all finding the right doctor is
just as if not more important
than finding the right plate of eggs
benedict maybe
on sock doc you can find every
specialist under the sun whether you're
trying to straighten those teeth or fix
an achy back get the mole checked out
anything else zocdoc has got you covered
its mobile app is as easy as ordering a
ride to a restaurant or getting delivery
to your house
search find
book doctors
with just a few taps
you can find and review local doctors
read verified patient reviews from real
people who made real appointments and
now when you walk into that doctor's
office you're all set to see someone in
your network who gets you so
all you got to do is go to zocdoc.com
find the doctor that is right for you
and book an appointment in person or
remotely that works for your schedule
every month millions of people use
zocdoc
and i am truly and honestly one of them
that's where i found my doctor it's my
go-to whenever i need to find and book a
quality doctor so go to sockdoc.com
milkshake and download the zocdoc app
for free then start your search for a
top-rated doctor today many of them are
available within 24 hours that's
zocdoc.com milkshake
zocdoc.com
milkshake
thank you so much
and now folks a little word from our
sponsor better help
you know
wellness
mental wellness self-care is so
important for all of us it's especially
important for me
i wake up every morning i have my kind
of devotional period which is meditation
and some prayer
um i do a little journaling sometimes of
course i have my weekly therapy
these are the things that keep me
grounded that keep me
kind of aligned with my life's mission
and purpose with a little bit of
serenity thrown in
so think about it like a car okay now if
you had the same car for your entire
life how would you take care of it
well that's how our brains work
that's how our psyches and our souls
work why don't we treat them the same
way because how we care for our minds
affects how we experience life so it's
important to invest time and care into
keeping them healthy
you know it's funny like even to this
day there's still a weird stigma about
getting therapy which just doesn't make
any sense at all like you like you
rightly said you know
we are all dealing with a world on fire
and listen
it helps to have someone to talk to
about all that stuff and what's great is
that better help
is an online therapy service it offers
video phone and even live chat only
therapy session so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
you don't need to go sit in a dusty
office you know in a waiting room with a
bunch of other patients this is very
private it's all about you and the
things that you need to get off your
chest and by the way it's also much more
affordable than in person therapy you
can be matched with a therapist in under
48 hours so our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
milkshake that's better
h-e-l-p-com
slash milkshake give it a try
see i wonder if it's because
of like the way that i was raised i mean
i
love my parents and my father has passed
my mother is still around and will never
ever
ever die
no she will not you know i think like
when i grew up like i i didn't come from
like the most you know functional family
and so like i always as a kid can't
really not exactly
no spreads i think there's like two
avenues and all rain definitely also
came from a completely dysfunctional
family i always i feel like when you
come from that there are these two paths
that go before you one is like i'm never
gonna have kids
and the other is i'm gonna have a
million kids and i'm gonna prove that i
can do this better and i definitely was
in that latter category and like before
when we were kind of doing research
for this pod i was uh reading uh perhaps
the preeminent expert on all things
women and motherhood nietzsche
of course um yeah it's my go-to my go-to
for any information on on women
motherhood he has this whole thing where
he talks about how one's view of women
is determined by one's relationship to
one's mother so he says quote everyone
carries within himself an image of
womanliness
derived from his mother it is this that
determines whether on the whole he will
revere women or despise them or remain
generally indifferent to them and
this guy is called coco cool cool thanks
thank you nichi thank you thanks for
that um
he sounds so chill niche is ready
by the way nichi also said quote usually
a mother loves herself and her son
more than she loves the son himself
all right
thank you i guess
uh it's projecting he's exactly he is
projecting
but you know it got us ready now we're
talking about this earlier we got us to
thinking about like how our mothers
especially
have either inadvertently or not
shaped us
as people not just the way that we that
we look at other women or whatever but
just like the way that we exist
as human beings and
i mean i certainly have a lot of stories
i know reigns got some stories his are
more depressing i think than mine are uh
but uh
is that something that rings true to you
like when you think about your mother
do you really
do you see the the relationship that you
guys had as
fundamentally defining kind of how you
see yourself as a mother is there a
story or something that kind of is
indicative of that
as a mother or as a human as a full
human
eyes are both both
i mean doesn't does nichi have a similar
theory about people's relationship to
their dads to their fathers just just
women
just men
well that's a whole ton of pressure
and i'm wondering if that is because
the assumption is like dad's just like
peace out normally and like maybe like
out of 100 dads like 20 or even in the
pictures i think definitely a niche time
that dad meant something quite different
that's for sure yeah because i think of
myself as being
very i don't know i'm curious to hear
for you guys but very much formed by
my mother and my father
and my relationship to them both kind of
in equal parts you know like i i don't
so i don't i don't think i agree
with our old friend
friedrich if that is history are you
saying nietzsche may have been wrong
about something by the way uh uh our
producer safa just told us that miche's
dad died when he was five which makes so
much sense i mean i guess if that's the
parent you're left with that makes tons
of sense i just think about like i mean
my dad has had a lot of influence on my
life but my mother
you know it's it's hard to shake i think
your mom's
influence like i think the things that i
probably
dislike the most about myself i can't i
can trace to my but i can i can
represent my mother and her relationship
to me with a single story when i bought
my very very first house i was 30
years old i bought a house
i was so proud i was maybe more like 35
now that i think
but i was so proud of myself i bought a
house in los angeles which is no small
thing
oh
and you know it was just you know it's
not a giant house but it was my house
and it was like i was so proud of myself
and when my mom first came
to to see the house after i had moved in
she kind of you know walked through
every room and walked through the first
floor and went down to the
second floor and then then she had to
use the bathroom so she went to the
bathroom and she came out of the
bathroom and i said mom like what do you
um
think about my house
and she said
you bought a house with a broken toilet
paper dispenser
there was a the toilet paper dispenser
was broken that's literally
all she said
about you bought a house with a broken
toilet paper dispenser how could you be
so stupid and i was like okay wow
what were you thinking this is me like i
am always like i always see the worst in
everything i am always like i i can
guilt trip anyone into just an early
grave that's my that's my spiritual gift
that i inherited from my mother the
thread the thread
yeah well i mean it's so funny because i
feel like um
i kind of have a little bit of and i
love you know i love my parents uh so
much
but
there's definitely uh i think they both
have a lot of that vibe of like uh like
i was a very
god sorry about so many brags but i was
a very good student growing up because i
was a real i was a classic middle
child i was you know middle of three
wanted to please wanted everyone to get
along didn't didn't want to
make waves so i just was like i'm gonna
just get good grades and do what i'm
supposed to do
like when i would get like a 95 on a
test
like my dad was the person who would be
like who got the other five points
so yeah i mean i guess that that vibe
can come from either side but
i've lost the plot i've lost the pot now
we're just kind of lightly complaining
about it well we're talking what we're
talking about jesse is how have our
mothers shaped us and this reminds me of
a joke it's one of my favorite uh jewish
jokes my grandmother was jewish it also
applies to persians by the way you might
get something out of this too which is
jewish or persian mother
her son is elected president of the
united states this is the very short
version okay they
the sun is like you've got to come out
for the inauguration she's like oh no no
i couldn't possibly and he's like no
we're going to fly you on air force one
you know it'll it'll be
either a kosher buffet or a kebab buffet
however you want to do it and it's like
okay okay so she shows up in
inauguration the sun is being sworn in
she's seated on the diocese and the
front of the tv cameras next to the
secretary of state and um he's swearing
in on the
bible or quran or the or the torah or
whatever it is and
substitute the whatever
book you'd like and then she turns to
the secretary of state and she says
my other son
he's a doctor
a classic very true very true but that
that relates to the toilet paper paper
dispenser but you know it's interesting
because for me
uh my mother left when i was about a
year and a half
and i
saw her she subsequently got married
three or four more times i saw her maybe
three or four times
before i was like 16 years old
so i
was not traditionally mothered so to
speak i was with an emotionally absent
father and i had a stepmother we had
some issues long story anyway
i got to know my mother as a teenager
and although
you know her taking off definitely left
some emotional scars um i think for me
uh she was able to step into my life
really right when i needed her most it
was kind of like
i was really lost i was in a tremendous
amount of pain
a lot of mental health issues i was very
uh in a very dark place really low
self-esteem
and she came in and made a concerted
effort to kind of to mother me to parent
me
and i remember the first time i was able
to really weep was in front of her i was
able to kind of express emotion like all
of this kind of like mother ring that i
was not able to get as a child all of a
sudden came into focus and really
enriched my life
and i you know i have issues with my
birth mother i have some very serious
issues but i have a tremendous amount of
gratitude as well because
she came into my life right at that time
and
so i guess my question is
you know motherhood is often seen as
something that you are like you just are
a mother you have unconditional love for
your child fatherhood is seen as
something that you do you do fatherhood
you provide you care you teach someone
how to build a birdhouse out of popsicle
sticks or whatever
that that a mother's life is defined by
a profound sacrifice that fathers are
not expected to face
but
you know this i was uh profoundly
mothered but not in any kind of
traditional way but i'm just wondering
if you had thoughts on again the effect
that mothers have on us
the effect your mother had on you
the difference that kind of there is a
profound difference it seems between
motherhood and fatherhood
and yet is it really such a difference
yeah that's such a good question not the
way i do it anyway go ahead
um that's a great i mean it's a really
interesting question i think like a lot
of
couples are you know talking about some
version of this question all the time if
they have kids um in terms of what the
expectations are
gosh
i mean
i definitely think there is a difference
in the nature of the bond i mean i'm
like always very scared to talk about
anything just outside of my own
experience so i can really kind of only
speak to that
um
i do feel like
there is
a quality of kind of like the maternal
connection
i have with my son i don't know i'm
really pausing on these words because i
i'm like i don't wanna
i'm just i'm it's it's really tough it's
a really tough question it's really hard
for me to say that i think that like
mothers
have like an inherently different
connection to their
children than
fathers do because i i think like that's
obviously sort of person to person
i think um
like in some ways i would say that i do
and in other ways i would say that i
don't i think i have like a sort of
gentleness with him and a kind of i
think like
i'm very
i think i have like a very deep
sense of empathy
in terms of like
seeing
need
in in him
like when i'm needed and i think some of
that might also be like my own personal
experience
and i
like with my parents who
definitely did their best and are very
loving but i think like
in some ways
like they could be a little bit
withholding but so i'm like very attuned
to kind of trying to meet this just
sense of nurturing again part of like
what led me to want to like write the
book is that there are times where i
just feel very
unconnected
to like
the kind of 20
24 7 drudgery that is mothering
and like i don't like to sit on the
floor and play for hours on end i do get
bored i do
fantasize about like leaving and
sometimes i also am very
lucky to have the privilege of having
like a nanny and so
i kind of like tap out a ton
but again i don't i think like the
expectations are a little bit out of
whack in terms of like
i get
especially at the beginning when my son
was born i think i had a lot of guilt
that i had to move through and
understand and
got a lot out of talking to other moms
that i could be very open with
and realize like a lot of people feel
that way and i think we're just not
really
allowed to feel that way and i think
feel very unsafe expressing those
feelings
so i i think i felt both like i feel
this sort of closeness the desire to
nurture and at the same time can really
feel like get me the [ __ ] out of here
you know
we're you know we've had these
conversations uh in the past about
nature versus nurture it's like
such a fun theoretical question to have
until you have kids but you do have this
one
line in the book where you talk about
how
you write quote i suspect this can
probably be traced directly to my
pessimistic little genes although it's
impossible to say how much of this
of of your son's inborn skepticism
that's what you're talking about um
exists due to cosmic chance and how much
is inherited jewish trauma
and
so i
i'm sure you've been thinking about this
a little bit because i mean this nature
versus nurture question is is one that
like
all parents start to grapple with
whether they are even aware of it or not
i know where i found that question
because i have identical twins
oh
okay this is very good
genetically identical
but it's like
the same exact input and two totally
opposite outputs but i'm curious like
where like where do you fall on that on
that whole debate
the nature versus nurture debate i
definitely as someone who grew up very
aware of feeling kind of
like oh i'm i don't really feel like the
way girls are supposed to feel i guess
or like i'm outside of the
sort of uh norm of what like girls are
supposed to look like or do and really
was into quote-unquote boy stuff and
didn't want to wear a dress blah blah
i'm very i was very aware of this going
into having a boy
very aware of like
how can i
not put these kinds of expectations on
him how can i
really just let him grow into who he is
it's so fascinating too i'm sure you're
both
so you know i think also as the girl for
me i was very aware of like all of the
[ __ ] around girls clothes
like i never wanted to wear pink i
didn't want to do
rainbows and so i wasn't really thinking
about boys clothes and then buying
clothes even for my
you know from the minute
they're born like buying clothes for a
newborn a one-year-old a toddler the
boy's clothes
are truly just such hot trash
everything is like a robot killing a
dinosaur
like
you know it's so aggro and the colors
are so ugly and you're just like can we
just get like a yellow a plain yellow
t-shirt please and it's really hard but
um
can i just jump in in the middle i want
you to finish i'm so sorry to interrupt
but i do have to point out for those of
you watching that i am wearing my pink
golden girls t-shirt yes you are i
i'm so glad you're pointing this out
because i i didn't see the golden girls
but i clocked the pink tank top and i
was very appreciative of it so
i'm i'm pushing against gender norms a
little bit
no robots blowing up dinosaurs but
please continue jesse my son has turned
out to be such a
boy boy in ways where i don't understand
even from a very young age it has a
little bit changed my sense of nature
and nurture i
really into cars really into trucks
his dad is not super into cars and
trucks i don't think we bought one
brought one into the home he's like a
little weird jockey jock jock this is
stuff from when he was like two you know
and it's just so not
the boy i thought that i would have but
i'm doing my best i feel like everybody
who has a boy has a real opportunity to
like make a better boy
how are you making a better boy i'm just
trying
at this age to really do my best to like
i mean you know as the kids say
normalize
talking about feelings
feeling feelings
like
saying we're allowed to paint our
fingernails if we feel like painting our
nails like just and just even in casual
conversation just being very aware all
the time of like when wimbledon is on
like we're watching women's tennis we
are reading books about like simone
biles like trying to really expose him
to
as i guess
fully human a spectrum of like what
women are as
as what men are
traditionally been presented to maybe
you need to watch golden girls with him
oh my god i actually truly just watched
golden girls the other day i was um on a
little girls trip with like my best
friend and we
were staying in our hotel room and had a
day and then we came back and i was
flipping around and golden girls was on
and i was like well
we found it the rest of the night
i just shot my uh a show on happiness
and we were in bulgaria and uh
number one most popular sitcom in
bulgaria no way yep
it is
undeniable it's undeniable
well those those nice old ladies
just uh
you know those nice
ladies who are two years older than us
you mentioned this earlier but something
i was intrigued about your very first
essay in the book is uh about
motherhood being kind of the ultimate
epitome of joseph campbell's the hero's
journey can you tell us about that can
you you mentioned it briefly but i'd
love as much as juicy specifics as you
can get into why
why is motherhood like the hero's
journey i had started thinking about the
hero's journey as i write in the chapter
i heard elizabeth gilbert talking about
it on a podcast at a moment where i was
in the middle of some very banal
or so i thought mommy stuff but having
very big big big feelings about it and
feeling every day like i was in
i don't think i'm overstating like a
real life or death struggle
with myself
and also having a young young you know
an infant
where
it's both the most boring and the
highest stakes sort of thing because
kids just can die so easily it's like if
they you're not watching them constantly
like in goes the penny or the marble or
whatever and you know everything hits up
but so it just i heard her talking about
like a hero's journey doesn't always
traditionally look like what we
think it should and i started thinking
about motherhood and
basically like the
sentence i guess that sums it up best
for me is like after reading a lot of
joseph campbell
and reading a lot about the hero's
journey
a hero's journey
is basically
a journey in which someone
in order to protect someone else
has to go through a series of obstacles
that are incredibly challenging
at great personal sacrifice to
themselves and at the end of the journey
the hero is different than when they
began
and to me
that is
exactly what motherhood is
every day
you are kind of by default
saving someone's life just by kind of
existing near them i mean especially at
that age again like just
the act of sitting and watching your
kids sort of doing nothing is
keeping them alive at the same time it
can be so soul-crushing
and so hard
and i think i said in the book somewhere
that you do
my experience at least and i've
talked to people who i think
feel this way as well is that you
do as a mother
have to kind of annihilate yourself
in order to
take on this role and i certainly feel
like i don't know anyone who has a child
who doesn't feel changed by it in some
profound way although those changes are
you know different person to person so
at least in terms of like this
this joseph campbell kind of you know
what is it the
uh
hero of a thousand faces like the way
we've understood this tale to me
we've just always understood it in this
very
specific way and i and i think like
it's very meaningful
to women and all parents to just think
about
what you are doing as having
the gravitas and importance of a story
that could be shared with people and
would mean something to other people and
that has me has meaning
is worth repeating is worth telling
i had never thought of it before and i
think it's a truly profound sentiment
and i think because
at the heart of the hero's journey of of
every one of those stories is is is
sacrifice and i think about my wife
holiday raising our son walter and the
amount of sacrifice that
she has put in i remember when he was an
infant and we were at our old house our
first house and it had a little pool in
the back and
and she
was holding him and like the phone rang
or something and she started to move and
she started to trip and fall
and she's next to this
pool
and she had to hold on to him
desperately like a football and just
fell right on her knees
and then right on her elbow and just
like blood coming out but and he didn't
even like cry he didn't even make a peep
but that was just like when that that
that vision is etched into my head as
the kind of sacrifice that she's making
she almost lost her life in giving birth
to him but then there's the little
sacrifices too it's kind of going and
you know the preschool graduation that
takes three hours of your day
you know all of that stuff the driving
to school and all of that you know it's
it also has to do with facing your
demons you think about you think about
the star wars saga the empire strikes
back when luke has that dream and goes
into the cave and yoda's planet and sees
darth vader his biggest
you know demon that he has to face
and so there are and you you mentioned
it briefly earlier about how women came
up to you and said hey i really
appreciate you
you know i relate to this book there's a
dark side to motherhood you said on
fresh air once it feels like one of the
biggest cultural taboos is to say that
you've had a second thought about being
a mother or honestly even just to talk
about the hard stuff but yeah of course
there are those moments when you're like
i can't believe i've gotten myself into
this and you mentioned you're not so
into sitting on the floor and playing
with blocks for hours at a time you know
other mothers can pretend to be that way
on instagram but that's that's not you
so
what is what were your demons in terms
of being a mother what was in your
hero's journey what were the demons
you've had to face that you wrote about
that other women recognize and respond
to i think it was just really going
through the litany of specifics that
feel
like
that
there was that thing that i i wrote
about like yours
you're shielding your child from a sword
that you yourself are holding you know
like we have this whole abraham isaac
story in the bible that's like
foundational
to um
to western culture and obviously it's a
lot to unpack
but it's interesting to me that
you know it's not a mother's story i
think there's just
for me it was like the moments where
i just wanted to leave
i just wanted to like
literally walk out the door and leave
and i
or even worse
you know like i it's
i had a moment
when i was working on this book where i
was at dinner
with an actress who i will not name
but she is a well-known actress
with paltrow
squid this is not good
but just to say i was intimidated by
this person i didn't know this person
that well and uh we were i was talking
about the book and i was talking about
how
you know i wanted to be talking about
like moments where like when they're
like around one and a half or something
and it's i think a lot about those
nights where you're just in this fifth
hour of trying to put them to bed and
you're hungry and you're tired and it's
late and you keep putting them down and
they will not go down and they keep
crying and it is crazy
and
i would reach a point
where
and i would never do this
i would never do this
i would think about like
throwing my kid against a wall
you just fantasize about it you're just
like get it away from me i would never
but i had a thought in my head
and i wanted to kind of share this with
this actress and but i was like i don't
know her that well i can't say
and i fantasize about throwing my kid
against the wall that is so
inappropriate to this moment and i want
her to like me so i was like oh you know
when you just think about putting them
down on the floor and never coming back
and she just didn't miss the beach she
goes or throwing them against a wall
it was so
relieving and
funny and dark and horrible but
also telling that just
we all have these thoughts and i think
there's something that almost makes the
thoughts worse
for a lot of people where you're just
like oh i'm the only one having this
thought
i'm such a bad person but in fact if we
were allowed to just sort of talk about
it you'd be like oh no
it's really normal to have these
thoughts because what you're being asked
to do is insane yeah this is so so hard
it's so hard and again it's sacrificed
time sleep energy career time's deep
energy career and just truly like
it's like pushing a a boulder up a
mountain or something it's so
it's so difficult so i think in terms of
my demons it was for me those demons are
just those moments of true kind of
rage-filled
impatience of like i can't get this to
be the way i want it to be
um and i'm reaching my edges like i have
a limit i'm reaching my full limit and i
and to understand like i
that's the heroic part is i think every
mother and i and i think all of her
fathers go past
you have a limit and you just somehow go
past it it's like a marathoner or
something yeah they now that i have a an
older teenager
a lot of the conversations with our you
know parent friend group is kind of like
it's the is the equivalent which is
i just can't wait for this kid to
[ __ ]
go off to college i can't wait to be an
empty nester i love our kid
oh my god please leave and you you're
not allowed to say that really you know
you're not allowed to say it and
it's it's a terrible thing to even think
but it's a little bit true it's not as
bad as throwing a kid against the wall
one of my dad's greatest gifts to me i
will say was i remember when i was very
young he did say to me
i don't this is my dad's a very deep and
profound kind i don't remember the
context of this anymore but i just
remember him saying to me don't worry
everyone thinks everything
[Laughter]
it was like don't worry about the
thoughts like like everyone thinks
everything it stuck with me all these
years everyone everything i mean don't
don't do it
but we all think it and and it was
true it's carried me through a lot well
honestly i think that's why we
gravitated towards the book so much
because
it is very honest
it does kind of
lay
you know all of motherhood the
parenthood in general out there and all
of its glory and its gory and uh it's a
great collection and really really funny
and heartwarming and beautiful jessie
klein thank you so much for joining us
thank you so much for having me this was
such a great conversation to be in and i
loved hearing
from the dads the book again is called
i'll show myself out essays on midlife
and motherhood and i hope you learned
something about motherhood from us in
this conversation yes i mean you jesse
not the audience
no i did again you've got four kids
you're doing the most
wow great conversation incredible
i i've learned so much what about you
reza i learned a lot i in fact i feel
like as qualified as you and i were at
the beginning of this podcast to wax
eloquently about motherhood
i gotta say i i feel even more qualified
now absolutely i mean we were speaking
to one of the foremost comedic
authorities on motherhood jesse klein
now we get to to name drop jessie klein
at dinner parties with other mothers
where we get to
talk to them about you know how painful
it is the amount of sacrifice that they
make about motherhood as the hero's
journey
yeah i mean you bring up anything
excited nietzsche quotes about
motherhood the dark side of motherhood
i really i could go on and on and on and
on and on okay all right yeah yeah i get
i think we get it uh and folks you know
we we've enjoyed this book and so we
have five of them
five of them
for our five holders listeners five
whole books it's hilarious and you don't
have to be a mother
to like it necessarily you could you
know
you could be a mother blank uh but uh
all you have to do to get your copy of
all show myself out by jessie klein is
to write a review of metaphysical
milkshake on apple podcast or wherever
you listen to podcast take a little
screenshot of that and mail it over to
us at
metaphysical cast media dot com that's
cast with a k metaphysical
cast media.com
send in those screen grabs and uh listen
tell us about your mom you heard us talk
about our moms tell us about your mom
you can find us on social media at
presentation rainwilson on instagram at
a physical milkshake
and remember to follow rate and review
us again on apple podcasts you can also
subscribe to the metaphysical milkshake
youtube channel and watch our full
episodes
every week
you know what reza before we completely
end this thing you know
we have been
uh male chauvinist buttholes for the
last hour i think you and i right now we
need to log off we need to go
find these powerful
brilliant
women mothers and we need to
really just you know
sit them down and tell them what
motherhood is i feel like okay that's
all [ __ ]
i'm gonna go do that right now
all right thanks everybody thanks for
tuning in we'll see you next week
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
i think that encapsulates i'm trying to
was i just father's planing your you
just made it you just you were here
father explained my my thoughts right
back to me and i thought and i thank you
for it
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you